desde fuera parece cualquier otro
autobús pero en su interior está repleto
de equipos médicos y maquinaria para
ayudar a mantener con vida los soldados
ucranianos heridos más graves se llaman
los hospitalarios son paramédicos
voluntariados de Ucrania y de todo el
mundo como Lena una poeta y activista
que empezó como voluntaria hace cinco
años
lo más difícil es mantener la moral alta
cuando hay heridos muy graves es difícil
sobrellevarlo porque en el batallón
todos somos personas empáticas es muy
difícil seguir el ritmo para no
desmoralizar a los pacientes
en efecto el batallón médico está
enfrentándose cada día a heridas
devastadoras causadas por Minas
antipersonal balas y metralla una
experiencia difícil pero que aporta
mucho al nivel y a las capacidades de
estos médicos es lo que cuenta Nitro un
médico en prácticas cuyos estudios se
vieron interrumpidos por la invasión
rusa del año pasado
suena paradójico pero la guerra es una
forma de progresar
nuestros médicos no solo aprenden en las
aulas también aprenden y estudian sobre
el terreno vemos como ha mejorado
nuestra traumatología como han mejorado
nuestros métodos de colocación de
dispositivos de fijación externa en los
pacientes y vemos la diferencia entre
hace un año y ahora las prácticas son
cada vez más profesionales
este vehículo se ha convertido en una
imagen familiar en las principales
carreteras hacia y desde el frente en el
este de Ucrania tal como el lema de los
hospitalarios ucranianos que todos
pueden leer en la parte exterior del
autobús para cada vida